the skeptical self consciousness thus
experiences in the flux of all that
would stand before it its own freedom as
given and preserved by itself it is
aware of the stoical and difference of
the thinking which thinks itself the
unchanging and genuine certainty of
itself this self certainty does not
issue from something alien whose complex
development was deposited within it a
result which would leave behind it the
process of its coming to be on the
contrary consciousness itself is the
absolute dialectical unrest this medley
of sensuous and intellectual
representations whose differences
coincide and whose identity is equally
again dissolved for it is itself
determinate as as contrasted with the
non identical but it is just in this
process that this consciousness instead
of being self identical is in fact
nothing but a purely causal confused
mentally the dizziness of a perpetually
self engendered disorder it is its self
awareness for its self maintains and
creates this Restless confusion hence it
also admits to it it owns to being a
wholly contingent single and separate
consciousness a consciousness which is
Imperial which takes its guidance from
what has no reality for it which obeys
what is not what is for it not an
essential being which does those things
and brings to realization what it knows
has no truth for it but equally well it
takes itself in this way to be a single
and separate contingent and in fact
animal life and a lost
self-consciousness it also on the
contrary converts itself again into a
consciousness that is the universal and
self identical for it is the negativity
of all singularity and all difference
from the self identity or within its own
self it falls back again into the former
contingency and confusion for this same
spontaneous negativity has to do solely
with what is single and separate and
occupies itself with what is contingent
this consciousness is therefore the
unconscious thoughtless rambling which
passes back and forth from the one
extreme of self identical self
consciousness to the other extreme of
the contingent conscious
yes that is both bewildered and the will
alluring it does not itself bring these
two thoughts of itself together at one
time it recognizes that its freedom lies
and rising above all the confusion and
contingency of existence and at another
time equally admits to a relapse and to
occupying itself with with what is uh
nacelle it lets the unofficial content
at its thinking vanish but just in doing
so it is the consciousness of something
on essential it pronounces an absolute
vanishing but the pronouncement is and
this consciousness is the vanishing that
is pronounced it affirms the nullity of
seeing hearing etc yet it is itself
seeing hearing in and so forth it
affirms the nullity of ethical
principles and lets its conduct be
governed by these very principles its
deeds and its words always the lie one
another and equally it has itself the
doubly contradictory consciousness of
unchangeableness and sameness and of
utter contingency and non identity with
itself but it keeps the poles of this
itself contradiction apart and adopts
the same attitude to it as a dozen it's
purely negative activity in general
point out likeness or identity to it and
it will point out unlike this or non
identity and when it is now confronted
with what it what it is just asserted it
turns round and points out likeness or
identity its torque is in fact like the
squabbling of self-willed children one
of whom says a if the other says be and
in turn says be if the other says a and
who by contradicting themselves by for
themselves the pleasure of continually
contradicting one another
in this long paragraph number 205 what
we're seeing is the truth of skepticism
being played out and we're going to find
out that skepticism by itself cannot
provide a stable ending point for the
development of self-consciousness as a
matter of fact immediately after this
we're going to see the emergence of a
new shape of consciousness that you'll
see quite soon so I'm not gonna talk
about it here why are we talking about
the truth of self-consciousness the
truth of skepticism well keep in mind
that skepticism itself was radicalizing
the moment the development of freedom
that was happening with stoicism
stoicism didn't go quite far enough
skepticism is in a certain way being
more consistent more consequential but
what we're going to see in this
paragraph is that there is an inherent
inconsistency a contradict country
notorious to skepticism itself and not
just in the sense of you know these
conundrums like you know the liars
paradox or you know if we're gonna be
skeptical about being skeptical itself
and couldn't brought that sort of stuff
up at this point but he's not instead
he's focusing on the role that empirical
contingent consciousness is going to
play in why the dam is going to lead to
a contradiction so let's see where these
starts he says the skeptical self
consciousness experiences remember we
have the stress on experience and why
that's important to earlier on self
consciousness the experiences in the
flux the the fluidity
the non ability to stay fixed
experiences in the flux of what would
stand against it
what would present itself is being
essential what would present itself as
being something that consciousness
cannot do away with its own it
experiences its own freedom and that
expose of experiences freedom precisely
by telling these things over here
you're not essential whether it's the
other understood as the other human
being or the other understood in terms
of body of thought that's been provided
by Plato or the Stoics or whoever or the
world or life all of this ends up being
just a kind of you know formless
shapeless empirical flux things are
nothing to be taken for for granted
because anything could change at any
moment this might make you think of
David Hume as well and his emphasis on
contingency so he says it experiences
the this it's only freedom as given and
preserved by itself so it has its
freedom in negating the outside world
and we saw that this you know this is
you know part of the way that skepticism
works we also saw that there is a can of
reflexive moment to this where it's
becoming conscious of its own freedom
this is very important development but
now we're going to see that it doesn't
remain consequent to itself in a certain
way stoicism was more consistent than
the skepticism was and that's part of
why stoicism couldn't go as far so he
said this self certainty does not issue
from something alien this complex
development was deposited within it it's
becoming conscious of the fact that
consciousness itself is working with
inside of itself to make this possible
the Stoics were able to grasp this in
terms of the eternal logos
in terms of something that wouldn't be
individually necessarily but that takes
place within this particular individual
from the skeptic this becomes even more
pressing as a conflict as we're gonna
see is the paragraph recedes between the
empirical and the universal within the
person within the individual him or
herself so it says on the contrary
consciousness itself is the absolute
dialectical unrest what kind of uh nest
an unrest out of here the world no a
dialectical unrest here inside of
consciousness itself this mentally of
sensuous and intellectual
representations whose differences
coincide whose identity is it again
equally again dissolved for his that
self determining this is contrasted with
non identical everything that we are
experiencing of the world we are
grasping in terms of thought you
remember that skepticism hand it's
Phyllis ISM hand this emphasis on the
fact that the world is for us right it
is in our thought and the contingency
the flux of the world takes place within
our own thought and we're not able to
unify it the way that we would like to
this is what the skeptic is actually
experiencing by virtue of being a
skeptic he says it's just in this
process that this consciousness
instead of being self identical is in
fact nothing but a purely casual
confused medley there's a little bit
more to that sentence but let's pause on
that the skeptic becomes aware of the
fact that it's not just the world or the
law or the totality then it's
contradictory that is confused that
doesn't have some sort of
of order that runs through the entirety
where everything fits into its place but
everything kind of jars against
everything else it's happening within
consciousness itself this is a
experience and this is kind of an
endpoint if you like of skepticism
because it's not going to be a very
comfortable place for the skeptic to in
Hana he calls us then the dizziness of a
perpetually self engendered disorder
that's very important there this is a
self engender this is a self caused
disorder it's not that the world is
screwed up you know if you think about
stoicism stoicism said look you can have
calm things can make sense for you if
you you know put the world at a distance
and just focus on on your side of things
focus on the fact that you have desires
that you can control your desires that
you can control the way that you think
about things you don't have to be taken
in by the screwed up this of the world
of course there's a universal look most
running through it but let's put that
aside for a moment the skeptic doesn't
have that anymore because the skeptic is
going further than the stoic did the
disorder is happening within
consciousness itself consciousness
possesses a kind of dynamism that
introduces chaos within consciousness
not merely border not merely consistency
this is the absolute dialectical unrest
that Hegel's talking about so he says
hence it also admits to it it owns to
being a holy contingent single and
separate consciousness a consciousness
which is empirical conscious now what
does it mean to be empirical it means
that it's something that we can
experience and when you're talking about
experiencing a consciousness we have to
be a little bit careful here we have to
think of it I can experience
my own consciousness in terms of what it
is that I am conscious of including
being conscious of myself the contingent
factors of you know the fact that I grow
a beard and my beard is not white when
it used to be reddish and brownish in
the past you know this tie is a certain
age and it has to be about tied in a
certain way because otherwise it will
catch up on itself all that is our
empirical consciousness that I'm here
rather than where you are viewing this
right now those are empirical matters
right
those are experiential I can experience
something of your consciousness as well
in the way that you can port yourself
towards me of course I can't know you
perfectly but now I can't even know
myself perfectly and he didn't need
philosophers like Hegel the time that
comes along good state knew they kept
them only you know according to
Augustine only God knows us perfectly we
don't we need barely know ourselves
right but we're conscious of our
empirical consciousness we're conscious
of our empirical position of all the
things that we can say about ourselves
we're also conscious of the fact that
those things are contingent that they
are not universal even if we might like
them to be so for narcissists they are
not Universal and we can't presume that
as a stand for consciousness per se as
you know the consciousness qua
consciousness for everybody the fact
that I am a 45 year old male roots me in
a certain way of being that being a 20
year old female may not the fact of
being here in America of being located
now in Milwaukee as opposed to being on
the East Coast all these things matter
but they only matter so much how do they
that's one of the questions that's
coming up here so we have being aware of
one's self as being a conscious
which is empirical what does that mean
in terms of the development of
skepticism says being empirical to me
it's taking its guidance from what has
no reality for it which is this stuff
out here the empirical world I am what I
am in part because of my connection with
the world and I know myself in part
through this this crazy flocks that
doesn't really mean anything so he says
it takes its guidance from what has no
reality for which obeys what is for it
not an essential being which does those
things and brings to realization what it
knows has no truth for what is he
talking about here the experience of a
lack of essence the experience of what
we call meaninglessness or alienation
what I'm eating you know I don't eat
breakfast cereal anymore but I used to
love a breakfast cereal so I imagine I'm
eating my breakfast cereal and I think
about what was the meaning of this
acronym well is to feed me and I enjoy
the taste of it and you know with each
of these things we can keep on asking
why why why why what is the reasons for
this and it always turns out to be
contention well it just happens to be
that way
well why this way and not that way that
is just that's just the way it is and
what creeps in there it is what the
existentialists called meaninglessness
or the absurd or anxiety or ambiguity
all sorts of things like that we're like
this doesn't make any difference it
doesn't matter at all there is no
meaning here that is what Hegel views
and has the experience of unassessed
reality of something else being
essential not oneself that's what kind
of alienation from oneself that's going
on there that's going to be a very
important factor so he says equally well
it takes itself in this way to be a
single and separate and continue
and in fact Anna life and lost
self-consciousness lost what does that
mean what is it what does it launch or
where is it lost its lost and what he's
going to call the UH nacelle where a
kind of confusion and what hands lost is
the universal it thought it was getting
universal by negating everything by
being free in doing so the universal has
slipped away from it
so he goes anemones says then I'm here
we go and also on the country converts
itself again into a consciousness that
is universal and self identical this is
very interesting instead of pushing it
off into the world to look for it or
into some other self consciousness the
sceptical self consciousness has wrapped
itself as being empirical and therefore
you know not very good in many respects
but it's also grasped itself as having
equally this universal side to it it can
in fact stand for everybody it can't
speak for everybody this is the the flip
side of it the realization that where I
stand does matter
not because of where I am not because of
who I am but in part because of what I
am that is a human being that human
being miss we could call it or you know
the reality of humanity exists right
here just as much as it does right over
there in you or just as much as it does
in Hegel the universal has to become
real in order to have it sort of agents
and it's becoming real in the skeptic so
he says from the self identity where
within its own the self it falls back
into the former contingency and
confusion so it realizes this but it
follows back into this for the same
spontaneous negativity has to do solely
with what a sink
separate and occupies itself with what
is contingent now why does it do that
why can't it just remain over here in
the universal because we have so little
life because we actually are rooted as
individual beings and a whole matrix of
relations that are in fact contingent
that you know are in certain respect
even there are very contingency is
contingent so we can't escape them that
he says this consciousness is therefore
the unconscious thoughtless rambling
which passes back and forth from the one
extreme of self identical
self-consciousness the the universal to
the other extreme of the contingent of
consciousness that is both bewildered
and bewildered Hegel is dealing with a
fundamental issue here that goes in a
certain respect beyond skepticism what
the hell am i why am I here do I have
any sort of purpose should I align
myself with what I find myself doing
right now is that like my purpose or the
meaning to my life or is it something I
should be in quest of I should be
questioning the narratives that I within
are the classifications so I can move on
to something beyond the you can easily
lose yourself in a kind of bewilderment
as a scholar that's a confusion and this
happens to us many of us had important
points in our life sometimes it takes
some sort of crisis to provoke this and
so we can find ourselves in the
standpoint of skepticism without
necessarily having had to go through
skeptical philosophy this is the sort of
thing that kaboom talks about as you
know the experience of what he's calling
the absurd coming through just
unpredictably you know you can't sing
when it's ready to pop up so he goes on
to something very very important and
very deep here
he says the self-consciousness of
skepticism does not itself bring these
two thoughts of itself together both of
these are real both of these are
thoughts of itself
which is thinking itself these are not
just ideas in its head thought is
something active thought is what counter
posed itself to reality over here
thought is freedom these are both ways
of being free being what one is but they
seem to have a contradiction they don't
they don't line up with with themselves
and this is the fundamental problem this
is the truth skepticism as Hannah was
articulating it so he gives us some
examples here these are there's a
wonderful passage as he says at one time
it recognizes that it's freedom lies and
rising above all the confusion and
contingency of existence and another
time be equally admits to a relapse and
an occupying it's off with what what is
not a sensual so you have to take a very
prosaic example of this some time we're
gonna read Hegel and think great
thoughts and try to wrap our head around
the whole dialectic of world history and
then we're going to go have a snack and
think I better check my email and maybe
I'll have a meal now and I'll watch some
Netflix and watch the story and now what
happens after this episode I should
watch that wait a second shouldn't I be
reading Hegel
shouldn't I be thinking these great
thoughts you can't bring the two of them
together you can try and you can tell
yourself that by watching some show
where you're actually doing Hegel that's
that's not really true is it so you know
we could come up with all sorts of
examples of this as well let me go to
work great example of that so he says it
lets the unofficial contents in a
stinking vanish but just in doing so is
the consciousness of something I'm
essential there's a back and forth here
right in affirm is the nullity of seeing
hearing etc yet it is itself seeing
hearing and so forth here's where it
gets really interesting it firms the
nullity of ethical principles why
because you know all ethical principles
really are based on something all right
you have to you have to begin with some
sort of social norm or some sort of idea
can't we just like question to all ideas
can't we strip them all away well you
know from a sceptical point of view I
suppose that we can and yet we find
ourselves having to live in a certain
way and even the choice to be a skeptic
is a certain ethical comportment as well
so he says it affirms the nullity of
ethical principles and the less it's
come to be governed by these very
principles the years were you know you
can think about the typical
relativist who says we you know we have
to affirm that everything is relative to
particular societies or cultures or
groups or individuals and then we should
respect them all what wonderful should
we respect them all if that's the case
there's things are always creeping back
in and it turns out that the reason why
we should respect them all is probably
not some sort of conscious thing at work
or in a Hummer Bastian worried about
performative self-contradictions
but more the fact that if people
preaching at you hate don't judge and
that's part of contemporary Western
society right so there's this constant
back-and-forth the empirical versus the
content less Universal we have content
here but not meaning we have meaning but
not content and how do we bring them
together
he says it's deeds and it's words always
belong either at one another and equally
enhanced itself the doubly contradictory
consciousness of unchangeable dissin
sameness and of under contingency and
non-identity with itself
so you can ask yourself where is this
contradiction happening is this
contradiction itself a third part of the
consciousness no this contradiction
something that the empirical side
becomes aware of and it's also something
that the universal side becomes aware of
and that is itself an achievement
realizing that in the heart of self
consciousness lies a unmask terrible at
this point contradict aureus so he says
what does it do
it keeps the poles of the contradiction
apart from each other
adopts the same attitude to and as it
does it is purely negative activity and
gentlemen how does it do this in an
inconsistent way so Hegel talks about
this point up lightness or again 82 it
will point out on lightness or not it
this is what the skeptic classically
would do you say green they say rap you
say I think that you know we should do
this policy they'll say well here's why
that policy is wrong and here's why we
don't do that policy instead this goes
all the way back to pyro neon skepticism
whereas every argument could be opposed
to another argument and the idea is
divine and flee that you preserve your
freedom that way but then questions
freedom to what freedom to do watts of
decide for something or not and he says
when it is now confronted with what it
is just a survey that turns round and
points up like this right imitates
torque is and here's the problem like
this wobbling of self-willed children
like like stubborn bratty kids one of
them says idiot the other says be and in
turn says be if the other says a and who
by contradicting themselves by for
themselves the pleasure of continually
contradicting one another now that
points to a very important issue
why would somebody remain within the
skeptical perspective it's really two
possibilities one is what Hegel just
talked about it's fun saying you know
doing this back and forth sort of thing
but it's only fun for a while the other
possibility would be just
I can't see a way to cast this I can't
find a way to bring these two together
daniel is going to outline for us a
development beyond this in the
paragraphs to come
you